all right Michael
oh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
um I grew up in a Long Beach California
so that's that's uh it was originally
from and
yeah and I've been out here for the last
five years tell me about your family
oh my uh
on which side my mom's or that's how did
you grow up you grew up with both your
parents I go with both my parents my
parents divorced when they were about
17.
um so I don't have any contact with my
dad
um right now my mom she's in Texas
how would you describe your childhood
um it was tough it was it was it wasn't
easy I mean it was traumatic uh I had
both parents that was mainly my dad he
was a really bad alcoholic so he was an
abusive guy
um you know he's uh you know tough as
[ __ ] and then my mom she started
drinking too so I grew up with two
alcoholic parents and I was uh I was
terrifying you know it wasn't easy yeah
what kind of kid were you in high school
um I guess
to myself a lot you know just very uh
kind of depressed uh
withdrawn introvert yes big time
introvert
um you know as far as that I just you
know did whatever I needed to do to get
by as far as you know making the grades
or whatever it was and and that's pretty
much it
um
I went I went for a little while where I
dropped out of school for a little bit
and uh at my mom caught me she called me
one day when I was ditching and she
figured it out so
um I ended up finishing a high school
with uh through home school I see the
drugs become part of your life no drugs
hadn't become a part of my life until a
lot later
um what would you do after school then
after school
um I was uh playing in a band so I was a
musician
um I was playing guitar and I gigged a
lot so I was doing that and I was
working part-time jobs I was working at
Guitar Center Hot Topic and
um you know just kind of did that for a
little bit and it wasn't until later I
decided to go to school so I I did uh I
go to school for a little bit
and how old are you now uh right now I'm
38. 38. so drugs came into your life at
what point uh I would say in my 20s
that's that's uh when I was when I was
playing uh I was playing uh a lot of
shows and things like that that's when I
was kind of introduced to different
things
um I was smoking you know first it
started out drinking so that it was It
was kind of innocent at first then came
from drinking then came you know smoking
pot here and there which was that it was
never my thing uh but then I was
introduced into uh cocaine and so that
kind of changed me dramatically that
kind of changed everything and then from
cocaine
um I went I started using
methamphetamine and that kind of wrecked
my life basically uh when I went when I
started using meth it just it just uh
kind of really really changed me so it's
been tough dealing with that you're on
mess still to this day yeah um then
that's that's uh I'm struggling with it
you know it's it's tough to let go
um I I feel like I could be okay without
it but the minute I get off of it
there's something or or something that
just clicks that just makes me go right
back to it like so I can get some some
setback or some setbacks something I
thought comes in my mind some emotions
stressful whatever it is and and any any
anything you know as far as uh whatever
trigger you know and and I just go
running back straight to it so it's
frustrating
where are you staying now right now I'm
in a tent I stay towards like a
Washington Alameda
so it's it's been tough the other day I
got my backpack stolen I was asleep on
my tent and my backpack I had it inside
the tent so someone came in unzipped my
tent and took the backpack while I was
sleeping yeah that happens all the time
yeah that's you sleep on meth you sleep
for days right oh yeah it's a deep sleep
so it's just uh you'll stay up for how
many days
um it depends some days I'll stay up for
two days uh most of the time it's about
three or four days three three or four
days straight but three or four days
straight yeah binging so it's just
non-stop what happens to your mind when
you go four days without sleep oh man uh
just uh you start to lose it uh you
start to hallucinate you start to kind
of uh Hear Voices you start to uh kind
of lose touch with reality so it's
pretty intense
um as far as the different trips that
you get out of it
um they could be a lot more severe than
the others but it's mostly it's just
it's almost like your brain's melting
you know it's it's really surreal tell
me about the consistency of the meth
that you'll buy
um is it always the same or is it yeah
that's the thing as far as dosage I'm
I'm pretty careful
um depending on on if it's really good
if it's really good [ __ ] then of course
uh you know I'll I'll take a little more
than what I'm usually capable of taking
but
um it's the point where
um
I'm taking almost
a teener to an eight ball a day
so it's tough It's a that's a lot of uh
it's a lot of drugs what is crystal meth
Duty or libido uh well what it does is
it it just increases the libido you know
as far as that so and that's that's
another thing too as far as the rush the
adrenaline rush that you get part of it
the full body high so that's that's
where that would come so then you go
into what kind of behavior
um it depends with me I'm a recluse so
as far as what my behavior I I I kind of
keep it to myself
so
um but as of course with that there's
there's different things you run into
someone else you know who's who's on the
same page and there's a lot of like uh
you know hooking up there's a lot of
things like that uh uh flings you know
just I guess you'd say like casual
encounters you know so there's there's
things like that and I've done that as
well too
what about sexually transmitted diseases
out there
um yeah it's it's real you know I was
naive completely naive about that and
and about the uh uh how scary it really
is you know I just recently uh
my whole world changed uh I was
diagnosed with uh HIV oh you were yes
how long ago was that that you found out
this was only six months ago so it's
still hitting me like a ton of bricks
it's still dealing with it coping with
it having to swallow that you know and
just so careful you know I thought I was
just so so careful and and I would
inject sometimes too so I would I would
what they would call it slamming so uh
you know I was doing that
you know along with smoking it
um so did you know he caught HIV from a
partner or from from using a used needle
you know just look at thinking back
um I it could have been either or you
know to become really honest it could
have been either or
but I'm sorry about that no it's all
right but there's all kinds of great
treatments now so yeah that's the thing
and that's that's what I've been that's
what I've been told so it's just like I
it's not the death sentence it was a
couple days like it used to be because
it's it's it's a killer I mean it's real
it just destroys your immune system when
they when I found out my viral load was
so insanely High
um it was it was uh it was pretty tough
to swallow you know little little things
like my lymph nodes were swelling up and
did you feel any different
um yeah I felt a little like I was
getting dragged down like someone's
pulling me down like I I felt like I
didn't have the same energy I used to
have
um things just were kind of off and
that's that's when I kind of had
kind of knew that something was wrong so
do you have any friends no I have no
friends
um I keep to myself uh friends can be
sometimes costly there's a lot of drama
involved so I just especially on the
street you can't really trust anybody
you can't trust anybody it is creepy so
it's tough yeah you're you're in a snake
pit oh yeah pretty much and that's
exactly what it is it's a damn snake but
so
and are you still in contact with any
family or
um yeah I'm still in contact with my mom
my brother lost contact with me he kind
of he kind of just uh let me go so to
speak he said that
um he felt that I wasn't going to change
that things are going to remain the same
so he's better off just kind of just uh
leaving me alone
my mom still keeps in contact with me I
still talk to her over the phone but
it's just kind of
you know how do I tell them you know
what's what's really going on and what's
really happening and how tough it's been
how really hard it is and and then
dealing with all of uh what I'm dealing
with and on top of that you know having
that diagnosis now so it's it's been
really just eating at me it's it's you
know my depression is pretty pretty
severe the depression the biggest
emotion you deal with yeah it's it's
it's the biggest uh I guess Crusher you
know living on the streets in a tent has
got to make it hard oh yeah it's it's
pretty uh it's pretty depressing you
know it's it's it's
um
you know all you could do is just just
sit and
cope with it you know do my best to cope
with it and uh
try to get get through the day fill the
day up try to keep myself busy you know
it's it's tough how do you support
yourself uh right now I support myself
doing uh
uh little things here and there a little
little uh little odd jobs I get general
relief
and food stamps and that's pretty much
it so my my income that I have as far as
money
is about 500 a month
so it's uh
it's pretty much nothing it's barely
anything
do you feel helpless against your
addiction
um yes sometimes I do I really do
sometimes I think like okay you know I
have a handle on it
um I think that you know I got it
together and then just something
something happens where it's just that
it just ends up crushing
um it's it's frustrating so it's
it's something that I
you know want to deal with
what do you worry about now what's your
biggest fear uh the biggest fear is
Baylor always and it seems like every
time I start something something happens
like some sort of setback
um something
bad so it's it's frustrating it's to the
point where I've tried so many times to
get my life back on track that I just to
the point where
I think I've pretty much given up
really
do you feel like your addiction may have
stemmed from the fact that you're both
your parents are alcoholics maybe yeah
you know I think about that from time to
time and I think that's
having that as an example you know as
far as your parents you know it's it's
it I think it did a lot more damage to
me than I really realized you know as
far as my behavior you know my
impulsiveness and everything else like
that I think that's where a lot of it
stems from you know it's just a really
bad example of how two adults should
behave you know and in a relationship
you know in a marriage especially when
you have kids so it was it's
you know it's disturbing
have you been in love before
oh what's that have you been in love
before yeah I've I've had a accent I was
with the same person for uh
um 17 years oh really 17 years yeah so
we were together for a long time and uh
um I have uh one daughter
and a stepson and um
she left me about
six years ago
I was in the middle of remodeling a
condo she finished the condo up sold it
took all the money left
and so is that because of the drugs you
think I think I think so it was a lot I
mean we
we're not Saints we we both you know
did our dirt and everything else like
that uh but she was pretty much done I
think it was the relationship
um I had I had Cotter uh online looking
for somebody
um as far as uh trying to meet somebody
somebody else so when I saw that that
was kind of just
my coming to I guess really seeing
everything for what it is that it's just
uh it's over
so it was tough and
um ever since then it feels like my use
my drug use and you know I've been
getting a little bit more I guess
intense you know it's uh it's been
consistently just Scrappy you know
looking back at your life what would you
have done differently if you had another
chance
oh if I had another chance I'd
I'd go to school full time I for right
out of high school I would have went to
college and and got my bachelors and and
uh and went went to work and you know
did the normal thing you know maybe get
into uh work with a government or or
even at one point I was even thinking
about doing law enforcement at the time
too really yeah how do you think this
living on the streets and doing drugs
and addiction has changed you
um
it's
it's been a nightmare you know still is
a nightmare you know it's it's it's
nothing uh
uh
that's what I'm trying to say is that
um it just it eats at you so you you
slowly start to lose yourself you know
as far as things that you
that you normally wouldn't do you'll
start to see that kind of that that bar
that you set for yourself or that line
slowly Fade Away uh with with being out
in the street so I mean there's a lot of
things that happen there's a lot of
things that you know I know other people
go through but it's just like for me
that's what it's been like it's it's
just in the setbacks of like all this oh
yeah it's it's been tough having HIV and
things like that just oh yeah make it
even more discouraging right very
discouraging it's kind of just what's
the point now
you know so might as well just continue
to use
who's your favorite memory in your life
oh that's a tough one
that is a tough one
um
man
I guess
having my uh
have my uh
my son with me and then uh
that they uh my daughter was born so
that's uh
it's a big deal you know
yeah I just I missed some you know it's
it's tough
frustrating
do you feel like if your parents were
not
dealing with their own addictions that
your life may have
played out differently yeah I think uh I
mean did you feel did you feel loved as
a kid
oh was that I'm sorry did you feel loved
as a kid
um sometimes they did sometimes I did it
you know I'm honest with you it's just
uh there was no consistency it was
either it was one extreme to the other
they were constantly fighting uh beating
each other up literally physically and
then uh taking out on us when they were
done so it just it just we got it from I
just almost say both hands and uh
yeah it just uh wasn't an easy thing uh
coping with all that when you're a kid
you know it's it it did do a lot to me
so
David what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned after
all of this
um
I guess a lesson
um you know as far as uh
oh man that's a tough one
um we'll just
to remain self-sufficient you know to to
uh never have never put yourself in a
situation where
um you know you're without you know as
far as especially the the bare
necessities you know housing
Transportation things like that you know
I I look at it and I should have never
let those things go uh when that started
to happen that's when I really saw like
wow okay this is real this is where I'm
at I'm actually a homeless man I'm
homeless and I'm at I'm at this age I'm
38 years old you know it's it's
it's
it's kind of tough to swallow you know
when it happened in a way that just kind
of crept up on you and all of a sudden
you really crept up on me completely you
didn't realize it was happening no I
didn't even realize it was happening you
know it's just one minute it thinks
we're okay and then the next second I
always found myself sleeping in shelters
it was that quick you know I just uh you
know I can't describe how quick it was
but it was a pretty intense you know
losing everything losing contact with
everyone and having everyone turn their
back on you you know it was it was
pretty extreme
all right thank you so much for sharing
your story thank you I appreciate it
good luck with your health and
everything else thank you thank you very
much